io non faccio mai ste cagate sono
proposito vediamo vincent amichevole
qualcuno qui mi ha tradito esatto perché
gli ha dato il cancro equa
mamma mia quanto quanto ne sai che la sa
lunga prete come il naso lasciamo il
dolce dopo la mano un abbraccio mamma me
mi dispiace allora ragazzi che mischia
questo è il dlc questo gesto
questo è il dialogo after di colore sono
adesso non da palermo qua da ciccio
perché volevo discutere con lui nei
nostri problemi in amicizia
lui non solo mi ha ucciso ma alla fine
prodotto dalla sua moglie alla sua
lettera che tanti che io ho consigliato
perché da buon amico
ma io dopo dopo che ti ho fatto l'ho
fatto fatta bella vita e di comuniverso
stato ammazzato nel mio migliore amico
perché ho ricevuto anche messaggi di
persone ma poverino l'aumento da tradito
lo so lo so che vi anima
mi dispiace non essere di rinaldo come
che si diceva a fare la morale è buono
seminato bene che non è di tutto dice
l'esperto non pare che infatti ogni
volta che va dal mento senti ma con il
naso lungo
tranquillo io lascia la natura perché
ricordo sempre che chiedi naso abbonda
a sei anni
ragazzi se mi dispiace per quello che ho
fatto vi giuro in buona fede
io non lo so c'è lo sapevo però non
sapevo di essere io il cattivo sì perché
tu mi prendo io ho qualche presentimento
ma non dirmi nulla ma non mi potevo mai
aspettare un pezzo di come lorenzo mi
tradisse potevi batterlo
si ragiona il pc mantova lento ea decimi
andava lento
leo è morto perché il piccini andrea
caruso è morto per una scheda grafica
nei capi certamente quello dove entrando
lab efficiente e più ros e metteva il
naso al posto della scheda era che poi
c'è la è morto è al cimitero che c'era
soltanto mia moglie voglio rinvii che
punta cosa dall'altra parte di sempre
stati tutti l'esercito dure che sono
esatte è la questione di naso sono dei
fatti sono retta dalla preso ed è che
santa savoia e ti apre infatti quando si
baciavano
esatto perché lino rava latina dentro il
poligono capito di che il politico ma lo
sai che a volte io conto dei ristoranti
no sto scherzando non dovevo mi sento un
po a disagio perché io che mi sbatto il
naso è quindi devo mettono in modo che
c'è un po più sobri mi chiedo si mente
il naso prezzi da una cosa brutta ha
fatto i conti correnti potrai cambiarmi
il bicchiere le parole sono scherzato
ranieri allora speciali incavature tecla
esatto le cose per il problema venisse
ci sono poi così che si versano che sono
il beccuccio tecniche
se non ancora ragazzi invece ucciso
umiliato tradito quello che fanno non
più bicchieri su misura che schifo che
schifo ma tu lo sai che per il video che
sta facendo molto per adesso mi sono
messo l'abbandona dimentica perché così
il naso diritta delusi perché dante è
lui perché aveva dato molto lungo ma non
è vero
cosa non mi muovo da una cosa è sicura
che guarda qua dante regalo di profilo e
dante già incredibile bellissimo ragazzi
è veramente bello che con un goniometro
quattro di coppia come alpha ragazzi e
fantastico veramente prende una parte
del corpo famiglie può chiudere sempre
su quella parte del corpo prodotto il
bellissimo
no perchè questo studio per questo siamo
vedo bene l'uomo
ragazzi io veramente per conclude volevo
dire che mi dispiace a me no mi dispiace
per incazzato na li hanno scritto nei
messaggi multis incenti quello che mette
il suo musica del nerd lo sta facendo
per isola lui lo sa
tanti ragazzi mi hanno detto no non ci
può insegnare l'amicizia in questo modo
perché molti ragazzi che mi seguono
issimo mi guardano e dicono cavolo
vogliono essere come lui no no
pare che ti basta dunque insegnare su
del quale persone 24
tu hai insegnato come prendere le i
vantaggi non avvertito una persona dei
consigli saggi e per cui ammazzarlo
allora faccio una cosa che siccome anche
io sono indignato
io credo che poi creare questo gruppo
team lorenzo team ciccio ovviamente solo
che di numeri vanti con lorenzo mai
convinto che a tempo no no no
dovreste siamo chiamati il naso tempus
erano ricercati con il naso regalato
quindi li comunque del progetto nato
in aldo team lorenzo tipici certi il
naso
ragazzi io ringrazio per aver fatto come
anche questo dlc ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto
grazie cc o grazie mille per la ricetta
è comunque tu sei mio amico e lo rimarrà
per sempre
grazie
[Musica]